all right emma let's kind of start
unpacking season five where it ends you
are on a plane
to where where are you going i think i
was heading back to boston
because i have my whole i have my
manufacturing facility back there i'm
always flying back and forth to check in
on that but i think that's where i was
flying then but yeah me and michelle had
probably just come back from cabo
you also kind of close out the season
getting very close to your client micah
yes
does that go anywhere has that gone
anywhere you know me and
micah definitely have something special
we're definitely still enjoying each
other's company okay so is there a label
on it
no labels there's no labels i'm enjoying
life um we're both extremely busy you
know me specifically like you know i'm
working 12 13 14 15 hour days some days
you know on the
bicoastal thing and things like that
obviously he's not 100 in l.a now so you
know that makes a difference i've done
the long distance thing for so long that
it would be nice to you know have a
relationship where they're in the same
at least
so there could be something there but
it's kind of it's it is what we saw it
to be exactly yeah you guys are kind of
right there obviously it's progressed a
little bit you know we've become closer
but um but it's kind of right about
there so
we'll see maybe season six there will be
a label a ring who knows who knows maybe
he'll build your family a home were you
ever able to track one down for your mom
no i wasn't so i'm actively looking
every single day but right now
so it's not it's buying right now is
insane i'll probably wait six months so
i actually in season six i might end up
purchasing a property there we go
something to look forward to exactly now
season four your ex was a big talking
point
we never
a good old accident we never saw who he
was his i i would imagine of his own
choice to not
insert himself into that the internet
detectives have done their work said who
they think it to be
um but this is all between your and
christine's conflicting stories
timelines alternate facts
about parallel relationships that may or
may not have existed actually first lies
i think it's best to call but sure
like i was with him for two and a half
years he proposed to me
he proposed to you yes oh my god did you
uh speak to him at all as that was kind
of airing out and getting his weight on
this situation yeah i mean i'm super
close with him we're still close of
course you know when the like fake
engagement was
mentioned he was
i mean it was mind-blowing to him to
everyone that that was even thrown out
there you know it was like
something is not right in behind to make
up an engagement you know that's not
normal behavior so
i don't i don't understand it at all i
would never do that but people you know
sometimes get a little crazy so that's
my take on that he was obviously stunned
and he was laughable to be honest with
you
there was some speculation that you had
gotten back together with him as season
four hit netflix
yes everyone is very infatuated with the
fact that we're good friends and you
know we spend time together and i'm not
saying i can never i would never say
that it's out of the realm of
possibilities that we could get back
together but right now
you know i'm single he actually knows
about micah and we have a great
friendship and
if it you know
you know turns into being something more
then so be it but right now in this very
moment we're just really good friends
okay someone who is not your friend is
christine quinn
uh and season five ends with more drama
between the two of you with you
revealing this alleged bribery plot
because christine denies that this
happened
of course so my client called me he
asked if i knew somebody named christine
i instantly knew it was gonna be bad
and he wanted to let me know that she
had offered him money to not work with
me anymore and work with her instead and
the quote was she is out to sabotage you
in any way possible why do you think of
all the agents at the o group that she
would choose you i mean i think it's
pretty obvious i think you know even
before coming onto the show you know i
had to deal with you know her harassing
me and doing things to me for years
years and i that was
a huge reason why i was hesitant to jump
on the show because clearly i knew it
was not going to go over well and
you know i've taken the high road since
day one since i found out about her i've
taken the high road i'm not engaged i'm
not and i continue to do that but at
some point it gets to a point where this
is not okay behavior and there's right
and there's wrong and you know she's
gotten to a point where it's just it's
so bad
you say an associate of christine's made
the offer to this client do you know who
that was i do
but out of respect for my client and the
associate like i just would never i
would never want to i would never betray
anybody and i would never do that but i
mean i know it's i mean it's a hundred
percent fast it's not just like the
engagement was 100 false you know i
don't understand the lies and everything
else i don't resonate with that that's
not who i am that's not how i was raised
well she does again deny that this
happened at all but you
have proof that this happened
i hope it's been you know everything's
been confirmed so i mean jason and mary
wouldn't have taken it so seriously if
it wasn't confirmed
is that proof you will pull out at the
soon to tape reunion
you'll have to tune in
what did you make of christine
not showing up to
her meeting with mary and jason i mean i
think that that says a lot i mean like
kind of
if you have nothing to hide show up and
you know say your piece and say what
happened but you know when you have a
guilty conscience and and you can't you
know
a lie
that's what the problem is is that the
truth never changes but when you're
lying you're doing these awful things
you can't it's hard to keep up with the
story you know so it was easier not to
show up
christine has
made it known since season one that she
will do things for shock value she will
lean into playing the villain for the
sake of the show i think that's a cop
out i think that you know it's more
you know she tries to blame the show and
you know sometimes blame production but
at the end of the day
nobody is making her do these crazy
things nobody is if anything she doesn't
want half of the things to come out i
obviously don't think she's a good
person at all and i am completely
different if there was two people more
opposite in the entire world it would be
you know her and i so i don't even want
to you know really
tie into her and deal with that you know
i have so many amazing positive things
in my life so i like to focus on that
there will be some viewers as they watch
season five though who are team
christine who thinks she did no wrong
who will take the pov that she presents
throughout the season that you all have
gained up on her that you all are the
mean girls what do you say to people who
might read the situation in that way
that is definitely
for the specific reason that maybe
they're a fan because if you look at
facts and you look at the way that these
girls i mean these girls welcomed me
with open arms and they welcome
everybody with open arms so if you
really look at the big picture there's
only one person that's trying to hurt
everybody and these girls are not only
my friends my family but they're really
good people
do you think this is the end for her at
the o group obviously i'm not the boss
but it's come to a point where you know
she's hurt each and every single one of
the girls so
i mean jason's gonna have to make that
decision but she's also saying things
about you know jason and but he's the
boss so
you know tbd i mean i don't think anyone
knows at this point jason's got to make
that decision but
you know
could happen at reunion i guess exactly
it very well could
christine
did offer you an apology
but you basically refuse to accept it
emma i would love for you to just be
like you know just be open to me a
little bit just be open
i mean i'm not saying it's completely
closed off but i mean a conversation
needs to be had with you know some
responsibility taken and stuff like that
i'm definitely not shocked that
christine is trying to
apologize but for me to entertain the
idea of being friends with christine she
would literally probably have to die be
reincarnated into a completely different
person for me to entertain that this is
actually something that i want to
clarify because when she sees me and the
other girls it's always hi babe how are
you you look beautiful
hey girl
hey
but at the end of the day i do know all
of the negative things that are being
done you know calling tmz calling page
six giving them my home address trying
to put out stories that me and my ex are
together seeing me and my ex out in a
group setting taking pictures of us and
giving it to the press
so i don't agree with that and then
definitely don't come at me with like
hey i want to be friends because you're
doing really awful things
behind closed doors
so you believe her to be the one who's
going to these outlets oh i have that we
ran into her at a restaurant she was
there we obviously didn't go up to each
other but she was there all of a sudden
from that day there's a picture that
comes out of me my ex there's another
couple and stuff there too it's a group
setting i wasn't even sitting next to
him that comes out on some you know
media outlet it's just
you know it's not
not there's something not right about
the situation
so is there no path forward like nothing
she could do
no
okay
absolutely nothing
yeah i mean i yeah no absolutely nothing
i think she's an awful person at the end
of the day i've seen too many people get
hurt including myself
big theme of season five is the
prachelle jason relationship as well it
ends with a very emotional conversation
between you and michelle
where she explains where things have
gone has their relationship and its end
affected
the office at all
you know i think with any relationship
when it ends it takes time to kind of
get back to
a place where you know you can be
friends again and stuff like that but
they've managed to do it
better than any single person that i've
known but you know obviously i'm
probably in season six you'll see every
you know things transpire and things
like that but that's just part of life
yeah
well
before we get there we'll get reunion we
might get some receipts we might see
somebody get fired what do you are you
bracing for impact for any conversations
are you nervous excited what's your
mindset um you know it's one of those
things where
i don't i'm definitely not excited about
it
like you know at the end i hate drama
and anything like anything like that but
i think it will be good for you know
everyone to kind of get their
you know stories out and address things
that have been brewing for a while so i
think it will be good for not only you
know the cast and you know the girls of
the o group and jason and brett but also
to the audience to kind of see what's
going on behind scenes maybe you'll get
an opening to what's actually going on
you know we don't talk too much about
press and things like that um
and a lot of the things that people are
upset about involved press and so i
think the reunion will be a really good
place to kind of address a lot of the
issues and and hopefully you know we
have some positive things to talk about
too you know it's not just but maybe it
will you know mend friendship and make
things better you never know yeah it can
go a million directions all right my
final question is
did stepping out on that ledge of the
pool actually sell you that house
no he wants a bit like a bigger whatever
house so that was fun but the picture
was so worth it so i'm totally fine with
it i would do it again i'm definitely
the daredevil of the group i would say
maybe you can take some jumping out of a
plane
yeah you can maybe you jump into a
broker's open from the sky
i love that idea
oh my god when when that happens you can
remember you gave me that idea i will
take credit for it
[Music]
you